beaubourg a fait peau neuve après 27
mois de fermeture un chantier colossal
qui a coûté 576 millions de francs deux
journées portes ouvertes portes ouvertes
par dons seront organisées pour ouvrir
le siècle 1er le 2 janvier dans ce musée
qui est l'un des plus visités au monde
cette réhabilitation respecte bien sûr
le modernisme de l'édifice en ajoutant
confort et sécurité
karine chanaye benoît véreux ont suivi
l'un des architectes qui termine à peine
cette rénovation de prestige janvier 77
beaubourg tout boyau à l'air exhibe
enfin ses entrailles d'acier aux
visiteurs parmi eux sept hommes et jean
françois bodin émerveillé tout d'un coup
c'est une architecture le paquet qui
prenaient vie et ce quel formidable
un coup de coeur et ça tombe bien car il
est aujourd'hui à des architectes du
colossal réaménagement de beaubourg mais
au fait pourquoi ce lifting et les
beaucoup plus d'espacés publics pour de
nouvelles activités ou pour déployer
toutes les grandes activités qu'on
connaissait nouvelle exposition
temporaire de paix publique
d'information et bien sûr son espace
d'accueil avant un lieu où on forme
d'embouteillage géant demain une
circulation du public et repenser et de
nouvelles activités comme un pôle
spectacles
hélas cet escalier mécanique où
mène-t-il raf est une grande nouveauté
traduction la bibliothèque du centre qui
dispose dorénavant de son accès
indépendant autre révolution fini c est
agir vert pomme la bpi façon jean
françois bodin c'est cela plus de
confort et de place 14 km de documents
écrits doublé de 370 postes multimédias
ce qui sera intéressant c'est de voir
comment le public va faire le lien entre
les deux
comment le public va s'approprier les
uns ils s'approprier les autres quand l
espace du musée d'art moderne décrit des
77 en ces termes le musée d'art moderne
et sans doute avec duga naïm l'un des
plus beaux du monde
il a été recréée à l'image d'une ville
on a reconstruit le système de rue avec
cette grande rue traversante et puis
plein de petites rues qui mènent vers
des espaces du modeste la pénombre et
ici la voie est ouverte entre ces
quatorze mille mètres carrés et 1400
oeuvres présentées il sera au 1er
janvier 2000
le plus grand musée du monde consacré à
l'art du xxème siècle